Kevin Kelley oh it's so great to be here
it's so good to see you man last time I
saw you we were at the next web in
Amsterdam it's so great to be seen my
friend John Barlow often so great to be
seen I like that very much
man I remember the last time we saw each
other we had a conversation about jet
lag because I was whining about the fact
that traveling the world and giving
talks is so wonderful but also so taxing
on the mind and body because of gellick
and you told me right off the bat you're
like I don't get well unfortunately have
no kind of advice about how to do it
because it's just something that was
born with uh-huh and so unfortunately I
wish I had some secret sauce or method
or pill or something that I do but I
don't there's something you were born
with just gig get the right genes and
you'll be fine well it feels like you
have been given the right genes for a
lot of brilliant insights because you
know we were having a conversation
before about altered states of
consciousness and psychedelic some
cannabis and you know you you know
you've never been drunk in your life and
you haven't done a lot of cannabis at
all the rumination or explorations and
nonetheless I find your mind to be one
of the most insightful creative
out-of-the-box mind as I've ever come
across you know your books have razzled
and dazzled my imagination to no end you
know what technology wants like shook my
world and so it's just it's so wonderful
to be here with you and and and where
does that curiosity come from where does
this I wouldn't say preoccupation but
this this interest in making sense of
technological trends and human
creativity from this this kind of
profound existential aerial view I come
from for you you know I I I think it may
derive in part from my kind of natural
tendency towards mysticism uh-huh
combined with my general kind of
the attraction to technology and
normally we don't think of those two
things as being at all related mysticism
and technology but you know there is a
kind of techno mysticism and this
interest in mind of looking at systems
whole systems yeah and I think you know
I'm part of the long now foundation is
trying to take a long term view of
things and I kind of realized recently
that that long view is really taking the
view of systems is this assistant
viewpoint if you look at things as
systems you automatically have a kind of
overview that's right the big view and
so I have been looking at technology
with the big view and so to get that big
view you have to kind of get out of
yourself that's right you have to
transcend you have to have in some ways
this sort of distant perspective and yet
for it to be valid you have to kind of
remain to be honest and connected on the
ground or else again it makes sense so
trying to stand with one foot in the
real here now and then one foot with the
cosmic billions yeah if you can do that
yeah then I think you can be helpful in
terms of looking at hey this is where
we're going yeah hey this is where we've
been hey this is where we are in the
context of the cosmos well it is it is
exactly you're you're dazzling capacity
of like big picture long view thinking
that I find electrifying particularly
with regards to your whole treatise
about technology I mean for those that
don't know although I can't imagine any
of these listeners not being huge fans
of yours but you know and what
technology wants was when I first came
across this this notion of the Technium
where you you you said that humans are
the sex organs of technology that
technology is in some ways has the the
characteristics of a living thing and
that it uses us to perpetuate and evolve
itself in the same way that the the bee
pollen uses the bees to distribute
itself and this notion of technology
again the long view as the the seventh
kingdom of life you know there's
something that we came out of the
biosphere and then the technology or the
new Oh sphere is emerging out of
and that we are smack in the middle
between the born and the made I mean
talk about like shaking my world you
know I've always been a sort of geek
when it comes to gizmos and technologies
and cool tools but to see this this
grand narrative and then to place us
smack in the middle between all that was
born and all that will be made and then
us potentially becoming as gods in a way
has such a profound mystical take on it
but here you are the co-founder of Wired
magazine you can't get more credible in
terms of like techno vision earring than
you how did ya did this relationship
between us and and technology this idea
of technology being alive can you can
you kind of briefly define that for me
yeah alive is a loaded word right I mean
our virus is alive so I I like to say
that there's a overlap there's a
continuum between all self-organized
systems which begins at the Big Bang so
the origins of Technology are ancient
they're go back to the very moment of
the Big Bang when we had something
versus nothing or everything and from
that long continuous unbroken strain of
things self-organizing from beginning
the self-organization of matter and then
a nucleus and molecules which are self
organized self-organizing into clouds
into planets into stars and then at
least on one of those stars
self-organizing into life and then the
thrust of all that is this very long arc
of increasing self-organization
increasing diversity increasing
mutualism increasing specialization to
all these things that we see over the
long term through life have been
accelerated
when mines were invented to allow life
to basically occupy possibilities that
it couldn't get to on its own
possibilities that
wonder based carbon-based things just
can't make like a car like a guitar and
so mine's accelerated this movement
through life to make technology which is
really accelerated life and it is making
possible possibilities that life wet
life could not make and so I see all
that we're doing right now
including this conversation has an
extension of those prime evil forces of
self-organization run against uphill
against the whole downward dream of
entropy and we have this continuous
thread of things becoming more complex
and more beautiful and what we are using
today all the technology that's
surrounding us in this city in this room
are all extensions of that primeval
divine force which is making interesting
things in a universe and so we're
connected I mean it's it's like all the
good things that people want to do about
bringing good into the world about the
the true and beautiful are possible and
made more possible through technology
this is not something that's against
life it's not something that's working
against the natural world this is the
natural or the natural world well I I
agree with you like a thousand percent
and I would argue that like so much of
my career as a speaker has become simply
about telling people something that to
you and I is obvious but to many people
is completely counter intuitive I mean I
cannot tell you how I guess narrow or
myopic people's notions of tech are when
they think technology they think you
know the opposite of a tree and they
think of like you know like rare earth
Emmett
you know rare earth metals that were
mining for and it's like creating all
this horrible pollution and like it's
the cities are polluted and people can't
free and any like technology is the
that's the cause you know this is the
effective technology technology is a
cause of all these problems and then
we're like addicted to our phone and the
software is hogging our attention and
we're feeling more disconnected as we
become more technological I mean it's
like it's this narrow view rather than a
much broader perspective you know one of
the things you said that I think is an
example that I often go back to his
technologies not just the chip inside of
your computer you know the musical
instrument is a piece of technology you
talk about if you really want to like
see how far we've come and how fast
we've gotten here look upon something
like a musical instrument and imagine if
we didn't have it like how impoverished
would humanity be if we didn't invent
the technology of the musical instrument
in time for Beethoven I mean sometimes I
close my eyes I listen to classical
music I am like that is the
technological sublime that is also the
divine and that is also God and if we
hadn't made that technology he the human
creative spirit wouldn't have been able
to unfurl or unfold right mediated by
that tool or the technology of oil
painting if you know if we didn't invent
that in time for van Gogh or the
technology of the alphabet in time for
Shakespeare like those are technology
your brain is a technology the heart is
a pump like like technology is
everywhere it's a nature and it's also
in the made it's it's born and it's the
made and it seems once you make that
cognitive leap you know once the mind is
stretched by a new idea it will never
return to its original position
everything looks different but most
people haven't made that lean and
there's this allergy and there's this
fear of tech and and I guess what how do
we account for that fear and and how do
you address you know sure that come to
you and like our write us with our
arrogant tools you know right yeah and
it's yeah I think people become afraid
when they don't understand
things yeah there's a there's a power
there that they don't understand and and
you know we all can sympathize with that
I think they're there without a doubt
huge problems that are caused by this
magic right so so this magic is not free
it doesn't all those good things don't
exist without many many bad bad things
okay so we have to acknowledge that it's
not as if this is only good new
technology will probably create almost
as many new problems as it has solutions
okay so we have to recognize that we
have to say yes
these you know problems of pollution and
stuff they are true climate change is
real so part of the angst about it comes
from people looking at that but and then
finally I think there is a but people
say they like change but most people
don't change is hard
really I mean if it if you get good at
something and then something comes along
to replace it it's it's not easy to
welcome that and so people have habits
people have understandings people have
an under comprehension of how things
work and suddenly it's disrupted the
first impulse is don't do that first
impulse is is that's probably bad the
first impulse and so I think we have to
acknowledge that as part of this dynamic
I think there's reasonable arguments
against all those things or you know the
ways we can make them diminished but
they are real and and I think it's a
natural and you know I think in the
thousand years now it's looked into the
future a thousand years
those arguments will still be going
mm-hmm
we're still gonna have the same we're
gonna still be wringing your hands about
the new things and we're still going to
be wrestling with the ultimate conundrum
about humanity which will never
which really underlines this thing which
is that we are self-made beings we have
invented ourselves that's right we have
invented humans are the first technology
that we made were the first animals that
we domesticated we are an invention of
our mind our language is something we
made up okay it was the first
singularity because anything that
happened before that we could not
imagine what life was like after
language so we are the created but were
the creators which is so beautiful and
by the way that's one of my favorite
feedback loops ever which of course it
echos Marshall McLuhan famous notion of
course we build the tool and then the
tools build so so that dynamic of we yes
we are enslaved to technology but we are
also the Masters of Technology yes we
are the children of technology but we're
also the parent of technology that
dynasts that that tension mmm will be
there forever so even in a thousand
years
we'll be wrestling with the fact that
yeah oh my gosh
we are slaves to this that's right but
oh we're also the Masters of it yes we
are being created by technology yes but
we also are the creators and so that's
never going to go away and and we have
to kind of embrace this weird situation
well it is it's what I call the
necessary paradox and I think
fundamentally at the very base yeah of
the creation of the universe is the
necessary paradox and I think that this
understanding or the embracing that
paradox is gonna require a kind of an
ontological awakening or like a forceful
reckoning or a new kind of understanding
and a new recontextualization of what we
are I mean right now we think of the the
metaphor or the symbol of the human
species as being like the DNA molecule
that's us I read this article ones that
can't remember where that was saying
that a more apt metaphor for what we are
it could be the feedback loop and
feedback loops is how systems work and
so if we think of ourselves as actually
the product of feedback loops then we
can transcend what David Chalmers and
Andy
Clark described as the skin back bias
and realize that actually what the mind
is is what emerges in the feedback loops
between brains tools and environments
that is research technologies then can
be seen as scaffoldings of mine that we
use to extend our thoughts our reach and
our vision that is a much more apt
understanding and metaphor for what we
are and so ya know no doubt we are all
connected and all is one because it is
one large system and you don't have to
be an astronaut that goes into orbit to
have the overview effect to have that
realization
some people have it when they have a
psychedelic trip you know and it's not
just that we are nature but we are also
not just the born but we are the made we
are our technology in our technologies
nature - I think it was um James Glick
in the information where he's talking
about this other Parisian biologist I
forget his name but he was saying that
New Kingdom rises above the biosphere
and the denizens of this kingdom are
ideas and ideas leap from brain to brain
ideas of infectivity and spreading power
ideas are not made of nucleic acid but
they have achieved more evolutionary
change and at a rate that leaves the old
Jane panting far behind I mean there is
poetry and Otto creation yes and there
is poetry in this Technium which I feel
is what we are yeah and if you want a
something to put on your t-shirt yeah
there the atom yeah you put on the
uroboros
which is the snake swallowing its own
tail that is the emblem of the feedback
loop that is the end of humanity yes are
you familiar with MC Escher yes so MC
escher has that famous hand right that's
drawing another hand that's right right
same thing I see what we are are you
familiar with the term ontological
design no but you come acting with this
means this this is a threw me down to
even deeper rabbit hole so I was
thinking a lot about Marshall McLuhan we
build the tools and tools build us and
this idea that we don't end at the edge
of our skin tissue but essentially we
are constantly being intermediate admire
thing we interact with is this like the
extended phenotype of Richard Dawkins in
a way but the idea behind ontological
design is
design has a lot more agency than we
give it credit and that the effects of
design are a lot more profound than we
normally are aware of and so they build
on the McLuhan line the idea behind
ontological design is that everything
that we design is designing us right
back oh okay so that we are actively
designed by that which we have designed
you put somebody in a uniform and they
become more conservative in their
worldview you know a chair that is
relaxing makes me feel more at ease and
a chair that is uncomfortable is gonna
make me more anxious see though and so
because design designs that awareness of
that can give us more stewardship over
what is really the designing of our own
subjectivity right through the design of
our external scaffolding environment and
so if the technical material of
subjectivity itself is something we
potentially have agency over authoring
talk about self-made God's made self
aware that they are self-made gods and
then the agency and the freedom of
realizing holy [ __ ] where do we want to
take ourselves right and I think that is
the ultimate question that we have and
that we're gonna be struggling with for
the next century and beyond which is
where do we want to go if that's right
if we really that's right are these
self-made beings if we really if
humanity really isn't a destination but
a direction a trajectory and we're along
this process and we are making humans
and remaking them and yeah trans humans
into something what do we want that's
right what do we want and that is like
any adolescent will tell you what do I
want to be not only is it a very
difficult question but it truth is never
answered until you die yeah right I mean
it takes your life mmm answering the
questions are like that right answering
the question takes your life it takes a
life to answer the question right it
takes anything can only be answered by
living right and so and so this this
idea and so in some senses we're going
to answer the question about what should
humans be by constantly remaking
ourselves and there won't any be there
won't be a kind of a destination oh we
finally figure it out
it's that we're going to constantly you
have new ideas yeah and probably
multiple answers and so but it's going
to be the chief existential not
existential threat but the existential
opportunity so well put and that reminds
me of the Walker Percy lines as this
search is what anyone would undertake if
they were not sunk in the everydayness
of their own lives to become aware of
the possibility of the searches to be on
to something
and not to be on to something as to be
in despair right and so for me that
search is a reason to get out of bed in
the morning it makes me feel like I am I
am part of the Technium in asking the
question but what's interesting is we
have the dual search yeah for our own
agenda your own who we're gonna be and
then for the human and ideally yeah
we're answering both at the same time
yeah right I mean what is the answer to
what treatments be but the collective
aggregation of all the actions of all
the humans trying to answer that
question before themselves and so in a
curious and way I'm answering the
question of what humans should be by my
own by designing my own life see I feel
like very briefly we should talk a
little bit about um this idea of
technology even though design we can
design agency into our tools because I
remember once reading this article about
it was in response to one of these gun
violence shootings and they were talking
about it the article was called the the
philosophy of the technology of the gun
and it was talking you know cuz some
people who defend guns will say that
it's not that guns don't kill people but
that people kill people that it's the
person but this philosopher was saying
actually the gun is designed to be shot
so a gun actually has agency and when
you enter into a relationship with a gun
the gun changes you and it changes your
set of possible outcomes and
the idea that that guns are value
neutral is erroneous and that we
actually have to be a lot more careful
because tools mediate us and mediate our
behavior so tools are not always neutral
and I thought that was really
interesting now of course I personally I
don't I don't like guns because I don't
like puts me in additional danger but
but still it was just for me I was like
oh because in the past main clinician is
always to go with the technologies magic
value neutral right it's a double-edged
sword you can use the alphabet to read
Shakespeare and pass down human
knowledge or you can use the alphabet
for hate speech political propaganda you
can use social media to connect the
world and everybody has a voice and
hallelujah or social media can be
weaponized fire can cook and you know it
was our first prosthetic externalist I'm
making cooking made us human or fire can
burn the village next door that's always
been my what we intuitively feel right
right but now realizing that we can
design agency into tools then maybe the
question becomes then well how how do we
design the tools so that they are
conducive to human flourishing yes the
opposite yeah and I think for me one of
the ingredients that we would want to
design into tools to make sure that they
don't become weaponize err so they don't
diminish our humanity is to always favor
things tools methods techniques that
increase options and opportunities and
the reason why weapons don't qualify
that is because when you kill someone
you've eliminated options for them at
least and world in general and so
weaponizing anything is a weapon is
diminishing opportunities and
constraints on purpose and and that's
why we don't want to favor them we want
to find the job for the technology where
it is increasing opportunities it is
forward-looking yeah it is
moving the direction of the torque the
weight into the future yeah is it which
is what options are
you know when it would I hear you
talking I remember reading your account
of the emergence of language and as the
first technological singularity and you
you talked about drawing a line in the
sand and here you had early hominids pre
language and how they could not have
imagined once they crossed that
threshold the world that came after
right like early humans grunting and
mumbling and throwing feces at each
other and on the other side of that you
have Shakespeare you have Beethoven you
have beautiful art you have cinema you
have Christopher Nolan you have
recursive thinking you have all this
stuff and how that that was like a
Cambrian explosion of an intelligent
right then and there and you describe
language as a something along the lines
of it turns it's a magic mirror that
reveals to the mind with the mind thing
Thanks right that we can't even think
the way we think without language that's
right right and and it was one of those
singularities like any singularity
that's not the singularities aren't
visible before him they're only visible
retrospectively and the joke I used to
make which is there's two guys in a cave
they're kind of sitting around and
chomping on a drumstick and they're
saying and they're saying hey wait wait
wait wait
do you realize that we're now talking to
each other never of that moment we're
saying we're actually talking hey this
is singularity totally it never happened
yeah never happened and so I think
that's why arguments about the coming
coming singularity are just not going to
be seen because they're invisible
yeah I'm during that process yeah and I
think yeah I mean language became the
tool through which we felt then
compelled and able to essentially
exteriorize our inner landscape right
right from like early cave paintings to
perhaps the pinnacle of language
consciousness today which is cinema
there was this book written in the 70s
by a guy called Jean Youngblood it was
called expanded cinema and I loved
movies so this resonated with me as I go
I'm at a physical explanation
he said cinema reflects mankind's
historical drive to manifest his
consciousness outside of his mind in
front of his eyes right and then and
then this guy called Bruce Cohen or
something like that
said that the reason we didn't really
have to learn to watch movies is because
consciousness meets its own process when
we watch movies that that we that that
cinemas consciousness externalized and
reified even back in the nineteen 1920s
or 1912 a guy called hugo mur Steinberg
first writing about the photoplay the
first liked video Cameron said that
cinema works more like the mind than
like objective reality the close-up
represents a tension the flashback
represents memory foreshadowing
represents thinking about the future so
in a way cinema mirrors the way our
interior world works more than being an
explicit reflection of the external
empirical right right and that means I
think we're gonna have a thousand times
that when we make artificial that's
right and augmented reality when we have
smart glasses and we look through and we
see this volumetric 3d digital twin and
we can do all kinds of things all kinds
of superpowers it will be yet further
instantiation of this consciousness
because it's that's where it's coming
from us and it's coming from our minds
and it's going to just going to what's
the word I want it's going to twin our
mind that's right in these digital twins
so it's it's you know Terence Mckenna
the psychedelic philosopher famously
said that like human intimacy or
intersubjectivity today you know thanks
to language and music and art on the one
hand it's it's really rich I mean I can
I can show you my inner world with a
poem or with a painting or I can bring
you into my room and show you my books
and and you can have some approximation
of what it's like inside my mind and
heart but he says that the full
emergence of virtual reality will create
a whole new kind of intimacy because I
will actually be able to invite you into
my mind right right so what new forms of
inner subjective communion will emerge
when when you know lovers don't have to
rudiment airily like rub each other's
bodies to tense each other's insides but
that we could literally be like hey step
into my heart and mind Wow
and I think when
talk about a singularity I'm bored by
this idea that there's some kind of
super intelligence which i think is a
complete myth but I am convinced that
this ability this almost telepathic
connection that we would have if we have
it in Mass if we have it on scale if we
have some an AI like aggregation of
millions of our own minds that are
connected in real time and kind of
seeing into each other that makes this
uber mind that is something that we
simply can't think about it's it's
beyond us
it's unreachable that's right which is
the definition of this cultural
singularity yeah and it would make
everything everything different
thereafter and that to me is seems a
plausible plausible route that we're
gonna be headed towards which is to link
all our minds together to increase the
interpenetration of mind to mind through
all kinds of technologies from
pharmaceuticals to electronic and that
when we do we will have something that
has never been on the planet before
which is a planetary mind and that is
scary it's thrilling it's unknown you
know it's it's difficult for me to to
entertain these ontology --zz without
recontextualizing the self there's Tim
duty he's writing about psychedelic
experiences which are essentially
profound massive recontextualization of
the self and he says that you these
experiences and these ideas they
recontextualize the self into a
marvelous conduit in a timeless hole
from which molecules and meanings flow
from neurons to nebula and back again
now most people seem to be able to have
a divination like this when mediated by
a psychedelic chemical or fasting for 40
days in the desert by yourself you know
like like the burning bush only appears
when a mind is altered enough that some
grand vision can seep through the lenses
of perception you I don't know how much
experience you have with with
mind-altering psychoactives but like it
seems to me that you are privy to
divinations of a psychedelic nature
whether or not you ingested
psychotropics I mean but it must seem to
you like you have seen the light so to
speak as compared to the default setting
of everyday I mean waking consciousness
perhaps but I think I think it's
[Music]
listening to the technology I think the
technology is trying to tell us
something I think this world that we
have unleashed I mean I won't say made
I'll say that we have unleashed again
has its own agenda has its own biases
and I am trying to listen to what the
technology is telling us ok just as you
might go out into nature and try to
listen to see what nature is telling us
there is this as a second nature this is
this is the seventh kingdom of life this
is a bigger nature and I think we should
spend more time listening to it and I
think when we listen to it says it's
kind of moving in these directions it's
moving into this direction where there's
kind of pervasive Universal settings
it's that everything will have a little
bit of a - mindfulness - of many many
many many varieties and diversities and
just as we filled this planet full of
life we're gonna fill it with Minds many
kinds of minds many kinds of
consciousness many kinds of
enlightenment and so and so that that
prospect is by listening to what the
technology says and it says that yes the
the kind of moments that we have of our
own consciousness and there are ability
to transcend that is not unique it's not
just for this package of meat that we
happen to inhabit it's a general
tribute of the universe it's a general
attribute if anything made yeah
well it's one of the things that always
um it moves me to no end is to to marvel
right to to be mesmerized by the sublime
characteristics of what is what has
emerged like designs that do show up in
nature you know that there are designs
in nature and that the sublime
complexity and elegance of these designs
can emerge without a designer is a very
interesting thing to entertain now I
know you identify as Christian right but
I imagine your interpretation of what it
is to be a Christian is very different
from Jerry Falwell
sure exactly exactly so so how do you
reconcile what you think it is to be a
Christian right I mean does that just
does that mean that you think that your
spirit survives death as an entity or
pattern of information or personality is
it a faith in the sublime mystery of a
universe that Auto creates itself is a
mystic take on Christianity in the same
way that Rumi was a mystic ecstatic
poets take on Islam perhaps
yeah I'm much closer to Rumi and I am a
follower of Christ uh-huh which was not
the last name of Jesus it's it's a name
of his role so the Christ is this is the
divine and so my conception I I think
you can find out a lot about people by
their conception of the origin of the
universe in God and not God that that
tells a lot about their perspective on
the world in my perspective and my my
hunger is to basically believe in the
biggest God possible mm-hmm okay and so
the origin that the creator of this
whole thing
you know it's any any anything you say
about the creation of the world and this
origin will be logically unsatisfying to
us well Joseph Campbell said God is that
which exceeds our intellectual couple
right so it's like if it always has been
that's not very satisfying what what
does it mean always we're to always come
from if it's made by being that well
where did the being come from that's not
very satisfying my definition is well
it's the self-made being it's the being
that made itself that is the God well
that's not very sad what does that
happen so there's no there's no there's
no satisfaction all are equally flawed
from our small minds and but but but my
unsatisfactory answer that I tend to
believe in because it makes a great
story is that it is the self-made being
the only being that had made itself out
of nothing or everything and so and that
is the that force is the origin of this
universe and that it is basically that
universe is something that is contained
in us okay the entire divine universe is
contained in me that's the Christ in me
mm okay the Cosmic Christ and so the
stories that we have on the earth about
this person who had the Cosmic Christ
there's a lot to be said for that but we
have to understand what it is that I
think the claim is and the claim is is
that we can partake in this cosmic story
to the extent that we acknowledge that
gods in us well had that speaks to me
very much for two reasons
you know the atoms in our bodies were
created in the furnaces of dying stars a
statement like that
is not a metaphor so there's there's a
there's a literalism they're like right
actually you know actually the atoms
that come that make up our bodies were
created forged in the furnaces of dying
stars but that should not make us feel
like a speck of dust suspended in a
sunbeam as as Sagan described us but
rather we are in his words as well a way
for the cosmos to know itself
we are the cosmos right in some kind of
microscopic scopic form like we are the
universe I am reminded by of you
probably are familiar with Pierre teh
yard the Chardon he wrote the phenomenon
of man and he was a Jesuit priest
excommunicated or kicked out of the
church for having a an interpretation or
a divination of Technology and the
coevolution of humans and technology
that that does mirror a bit the
interpretation of the Technium and he
saw evolution as essentially
teleological mmm-hmm which is I think
another word for EXO trophic the
opposite of entropy so you had something
that moves towards greater complexity
and organization and it's the same
forces that allowed single-celled
organisms too caught up in multicellular
organisms and then they become primates
and those primates can cut up in
self-awareness and then they start to
exteriorize their own imaginations and
so on and so forth that has a
directionality right that's moving
towards what was very simple and
rudimentary towards something that's
sublime and elegant and eventually
became a Beethoven symphony I mean Wow
and and that that was gonna take us to a
kind of Omega void which is what a
stand-in for another word to be a
singularity which we've heard or do you
have do you have a word you use for
where the Technium is leading us to
right so by one little kind of
disagreement with yeah sure done which
and generally I adhere to the same kind
of large-scale strokes you just painted
is that I think my image of what's
happening is more so a radiation outward
complete climatic explosion which is
great ain't readying outward and
evolution in fact is not some kind of
ladder
moving us up to this end point of the
Omega Point but in fact it is something
that's rating our like an expanding
universe going out and now now almost
infinitely and so maybe there is some
moment when the godhood brings all back
in and returns it to itself yeah but I
doubt that I doubt I think that it
returns by never coming back all right
it's curved like a mobius strip which
which is just sort of recurving back
into itself but I so so I that one
picture the one little image that kind
of disagree with this is I that there is
of an end state whereas I would say
there's end States I would say that
there's kind of no way and there is just
this movement of increasing diversity of
increasing options of increasing
possibilities this kind of abundance
this the super abundance where the the
the mission my mission is I understand
this kind of picture in my time my short
time on earth my mission is to surprise
god that's so beautiful it's there's a
line by flow bear I'm gonna paraphrase
it but he says human speech is but it
cracked kettle on which we tap crude
rhythms while we long to make music that
will melt the stars right is that
granted I love language but I think he
was saying that like yeah as sublime and
magnificent as our poetry is it's only a
pale approximation of what our desire
our existential yearning is like what we
want is to make music that will melt the
stars what sounds to me like I want to
surprise God right the same thing that I
want so you have this majestic infinite
power yeah conception that could have
made everything but the the genius the
game was he makes beings that reflects
some of its own power of creation chance
a you make it
surprise me mm-hmm mmm it's like that is
that's my Christianity sure is that and
then we ourselves to go we're going to
make other beings that have a
consciousness and free will and we're
going to say surprise us mm-hmm and the
beings that we're gonna create oh so you
talked about that too he says that when
we start creating virtual realities with
virtual mind and we'll have an
appreciation of our own godhood exactly
because we'll find out that it's not
easy being God right it's really tough
it's really tough because you have to
assume the responsibilities for anything
that goes awry you and then this again
comes to my conception of Christianity
is how do you how do you redeem if you
make a world and you make beings that
themselves start to harm each other what
do you do mmm
how do you how do you how do you
reconcile the justice that's necessary
with the mercy that you have for your
creation and one of the ways is is that
you can take upon yourself the the the
price of those things and so I think
once we begin to be God's on a regular
basis whether now or in the long-term
future we're gonna realize that there's
sort of a an art to being God and and
and I think we may return to some of the
ancient religions for guidance sure how
to be a good God mmm so elegant I would
like to ask you about peak experiences
you know this whole notion that um we
spend a lot of water sorry we spend a
lot of time fetching water and chopping
wood that that's also part of the human
condition you know to keep our heads
down and to go build a stuff and to get
things done and to take care of our
family in our community
after the ecstacy the laundry so to
splay but I want to ask you where you go
for your ecstasy and do you think that
these moments of ecstasy when we step
outside ourselves these transcendent
moments that nourish us so deeply are
they divinations are they glimpses
of an unseen order you know when you
experience aesthetic arrest you know
Joseph Campbell talks about aesthetic
arrest I know you travel a lot so I
imagine that novelty and encounters that
violate your expectations hurl you into
a domain of you know f scott fitzgerald
notion of transitory enchanted moments
in which you're compelled into aesthetic
contemplations face to face with
something can measure to your capacity
for wonder and and I live for aesthetic
arrest you know I live for the aesthetic
orgasm or the musical skin orgasm the
exhilarating neuro storm of intense
intellectual pleasure and now positive
psychologists are telling us that any
experience of such perceptual expansion
or such perceptual vastness that your
mental models of the world have to be
obliterated and rebuilt to accommodate
this new experience leaves us with this
lasting afterglow of increased
creativity increased well-being and
increased compassion so where do you go
for your all where do you go for your
wonder where do you go for your ecstasy
and aesthetic arrest
so I'm covers you know kind of a person
who lives a lot in their head and so you
mentioned Rumi yeah I actually late at
night sitting in a favorite chair will
pull out Rumi and read some and just
have my mind blown and there it's blown
not in the sense of like this
intellectual fireworks but blown in the
sense of an aha a you know a
rearrangement of perspectives of like I
see and I also just you know kind of
trippy science fiction reading where I'm
forced to see things from a totally
different perspective like you know to
imagine them a a Martian and that to me
is as provoking as anything else I could
imagine if I could really for a few
minutes see humans as a Martian would
that is sufficient for me to kind of
have that that enlightenment moment then
that kind of epiphany and I think you're
right that that I do travel looking for
those kinds of moments I the the most
recent one was actually not one I had I
was in a dinner party last night and
there was a doctor describing his travel
with his kids to Pompeii and he was at
loss for words for this moment when he
was there with his kids after seeing all
these other things Italy and then having
this moment of this kind of you know the
snapshot that you get where this the
volcano ash came and they caught people
right in their lives and he was like
that could have been us mm-hmm that that
was I mean we're no different where you
mean there could be something right now
that just eliminates us right in this
moment with the clothes still draped on
the edge of the bed terrifying to think
about what wasn't terrifying for him it
was aware of epiphany was more of like
an illumination like a strobe of our
lives and it's in their relation to the
cosmos which is that it's momentarily
that it's a very short moment so you
know he basically like he wanted to hug
his family and just renew that important
thing on this short ride that we have
which is that we're here together and
we're on this ride and our embodiment is
a gift this should not be squandered and
so he's trying to make the most of it
from that moment and I think I have I've
had moments like that just traveling and
it's we're almost not that it's the
esoteric yeah that triggers it but more
of a mundane moment that is shared
somewhere that seems strange and you're
reminded of the power of the ordinary in
our own lives
and how precious the ordinary is or we
take for granted this this embodiment
I'm you know I the image that I have all
the time
is that there are angels in heaven who
are weeping over us because we're
squandering our embodiment we have this
ultimate VR ride which is like we're in
this flesh we're in these meat sacks we
can taste mango we can hear music we can
have sex we can feel the window in our
skin we can have a fight if we wanted to
we can actually affect things whereas
them in their celestial omniscience they
can't do anything they can have no
effect they can only look at us and say
oh if I was down on earth and had a body
I would not be just wasting it watching
another rerun on Netflix I would be
doing something else
with this body that we have and and this
raises a good question you know we we
began our conversation talking about you
being the technologist but also kind of
a mystic more having having divinations
of a mystical nature that have informed
your your views of Technology the way
you see technology William James the
psychologist back in the day identified
these characteristics that if people had
a sufficiently powerful experience that
met all this criteria no transcendence
of time and place a sense of the noetic
or some glimpsing some ultimate truth a
sense of being able to apprehend
paradoxic ality holding multiple truths
in mind that one's the whole thing if
you met this criteria that was a
mystical experience that was considered
a mystical experience now you know we're
living in an era of unprecedented amount
of mental distress people suffering from
anxiety disorders depression all these
diseases characterized by excessive
rumination and rigid thinking the
opposite of cognitive flexibility and
openness the people are trapped in their
own lenses of perception their their
past traumas or there's feelings of
alienation and disconnection in the past
they are bringing to the doorstep of
every moment and they don't see the
world as it is they see the world as
they are essentially a generation of
people who are traumatized and what's
happening is psychiatry is is
desperately looking for a new a new
approach and so psychedelics are having
a kind of renaissance Johns Hopkins
University led by roland griffiths and
weiu led by Steven Ross Imperial College
of London there's all these places
around the world that are now bringing
in people who are suffering from
end-of-life anxiety treatment resistant
depression etc people who are trapped in
their interpretive frameworks that are
not serving them and they are
administering LSD psilocybin MDMA and
other psychoactives and in control and
guided environments are essentially
inducing mystical experiences of the
type that no doubt you have had and have
informed your work and your life and the
poetry of what you speak and in roland
griffiths describes these experiences
akin to a kind of inverse PTSD so in the
same way that a trauma can sideline you
and warp your world and make it go dark
and then make you bring that darkness to
the doorstep of every moment with a kind
of existential nihilism and fear that
the opposite is similarly true but in a
positive way that a sufficiently
beautiful mystical enrapturing
divination where you see the whole the
long view the overview effect as you
spoke about before that can have these
like lasting cognitive benefits so I'm
curious as to you know as we unwind here
your your take on you know what was
described as potentially being for
psychiatry what the telescope was for
astronomy in terms of a capacity to
explore and probe the the landscapes of
inside the new space is inner space what
is your take on this psychedelic
Renaissance and perhaps you can talk
about your own experience with LSD yes
so I have very limited experiences I
have had only two basically two drug
experiences when I was a teenager
it's a dentist's office I had nitrous
oxide on a you know whenever I visited
and I got very very high and I had out
of the body experiences and it as a
teenager which in the 1960s were
completely unknown I mean I had nobody
talk to I didn't know what they were it
took wasn't until the 70s that even had
even a vocabulary to talk about him but
they were formative because they those
out of the body Astro experiences were
absolutely realer than this life so I
had this glimpse into the real reality
behind our imaginary reality and that
stayed with me forever but then and that
was enough so I didn't really engage in
anything else even though I lived among
hippies and everybody around was taking
it I just didn't have any need for it
but when I was 50 I decided that I
should experience a sacrament of LSD I
took it as a sacramental and this is
again before Fadiman it all had anything
published about how to do this how much
to take I searched really far to find
anything there were no guides at that
time so I found somebody
Stewart Brand who and I got some LSD
from John parley jump Barlow and I
trusted those sources and I had a I had
a sacramental day when I took it and I
saw God and but it was sort of the word
I uses actually favorite word of yours
which was that it was awesome awesome aw
if you know the origins of all he used
to be also fear it is not a friendly oh
this is like oh my gosh yeah I am
looking at the creator of the universe
and this is like I need a you know my my
my brows are singed it's like whoa and I
felt like you're saying because you felt
that your vessel couldn't hold right
that divine fluid right Carl Jung used
to say beware of unearned wisdom right
right it's like you know the faucet is
dripping and you can take these
divinations but if you turn it on it
becomes angel falls in your face like
there's no way you can a cop
Nate what's coming in is that akin to
what it was very much like it was just
the it was like coming to the edge of
the Big Bang it's like okay I'm I'm just
I'm just gonna get run over here yeah
exactly so it wasn't this kind of
peaceful at one with the universe it was
more like oh my gosh I need to stand
back did you panic no no I did and and
so I think the result of that was I had
a transcendent experience you know the
kind of mood that I might have expected
wasn't it was a different mood it was
still very very powerful but I didn't
feel like I need to repeat that
it wasn't bad it was just wasn't like i
mean i i'd already believed in the idea
that i'm one with the universe and stuff
is like okay I know that yeah well the
way you live and the things you write
about and the thoughts you have of
course mirror you know Terence for
Timothy Leary's to say find the others
and immediately you know when you when
you recognize something in writing it's
like what you're really recognizing is
parts of you resonates it's like wow
this is playing me like a melody there
must be some pattern here that matches
patterns I'm thinking and so we we kind
of find each other and so you know you
are psychedelics yes sorry I'm concerned
just like Salvador Dali used to say I
don't take drugs I am I don't think that
people that everybody needs LSD to have
an LSD like mystical experience clearly
they can spontaneously arise under the
right neurochemical conditions you know
I myself have experimented well for
years having intentionally been using
cannabis which is also a plant medicine
and Rick Doblin told me look cannabis
will take you as far as LSD if you let
it but that has also made me a bit more
apprehensive about taking stronger doses
I've been mushrooms because my whole
thing is I don't want to turn the faucet
into Angel Falls right right right now I
like the idea there was a neurosciences
that I listened to once on a on a
podcast who said that human beings are
not omnivores or carnivores
were info Vorst and that what we really
want to eat his new interpretable
information and I thought it was
interesting because he was saying
basically novelty junkies were explorers
right right but that he used
interpretable in their new interpretable
information but if it's not interprete
ballif I can't internalize it or
assimilate it or language it or do
something with it I don't want to drown
I want to surf I want to surf the
universe I don't want to wipe out and be
underwater not be able to breathe sure
so so these these drugs these
pharmaceuticals are technologies that's
right we've invented there its
technological as the headphones that we
have on right now that's right and I
hate them completely expecting that
there'll be new devices new molecules
invented that will do all kinds of
things and I think part of them will be
informed by our continual discoveries of
how our brain works which is something
we don't really understand right now and
I think one of the prime forces in
understanding how our minds work will be
AI mm-hmm
not that the AI is going to solve it
which it will help but primarily the act
the trials the experiments in trying to
make artificial Minds will be the
telescope that we use the microscope for
understanding how the minds work and so
as we begin to understand how the minds
work
we will also pair that with making new
devices some of them being chemicals and
others electronic or laser that could
look into them our mind it may in on
evasive way and actually not only read
it but actually to begin to affect it
and so that the technologies of the
psychedelic yeah will explode at that
point and it will have many ways in
which we can nudge us in certain
directions at which we could maybe spark
a transcendent moment using something
that we my skull cap and we put on and
so I think that would be incredibly
powerful because that because I think
the kinds of states that you are
interested in that your listeners are
interested in are part of being human
and I think as we make ourselves better
humans that we are going to engineer our
ability to do that in a one more
controlled way to do it in a more
powerful way yeah and it'll be something
that we'll learn how to do better yeah
well that sounds a lot like David Pierce
out of the UK he's a philosopher he
wrote the hedonistic impaired and just
this wonderful treatise or document in
which he advocates for deploying
biotechnology and nanotechnology to
basically reprogram human subjectivity
from the inside out and basically
divinized our selves with gradients of
bliss that are way beyond our Darwinian
heart Darwinian heritage right and and
he writes a lot about MDMA as being a
glimpse of the perfect human state but
that of course it's not something people
can do every day now because I like
neurotoxicity or whatever but that
eventually we can get windows into
what's possible for personhood and
subjectivity in pathogenic ceratin Gen
X's girls and compounds that we could
perfect and modulate and eventually
design better Minds for ourselves
and and you may not be doing it every
day even when it's right well perfected
yeah it may be something like lots of
things we have in our lives that we
don't do on a continual basis one
because of the fact that we get used to
things and they're more powerful but
just also because I think part of what
we were going to do as humans is to
expand the range of things that we want
to do we may not want to be in bliss all
the time that's right okay and so so so
I think there'll be many mine states
that we can engineer and right now we
have a kind of I would I would say
looking back from a 500 years from now
we'll realize that our language at this
time was very very very crude could we
had only a few words like transcended
our consciousness yeah when in fact they
were like probably 25 things they're all
very different they were actually being
squeezed and crammed into this one word
because we just weren't sophisticate
enough to make the distinctions but
there are probably many different states
of things and we now call consciousness
and later on unravel you know at the
tail end of our conversation I feel like
we've just we've leaf what is it that
McLuhan said he's confident that we'll
learn to sing the songs that orchestrate
the universe knowing what you know and
tasting what you've tasted and the
intellection and the reflections in the
poetry what what can you tell people out
there who feel disconnected or depressed
or nihilistic or anxious you know what's
your prescription or some some words
that you might offer them to give them
another place from which to CERN's so
first of all it's common it's normal
it's part of being human is to have
these moments I think the goal is to not
have it be the primary thing is to have
other varieties of experiences besides
that so and I think the way into that is
by for me it's by seeing or enlarging
the environment that we're in to realize
that we are part of something much
bigger than ourselves and so it's it's a
it's a way to take ourselves out of our
current problem and to transcend that
moment a feeling imprisoned and whatever
we can do to hook up or to escape from
that into the larger story that's being
taken place and for some people that
could be a cause other it could be
religion framework it could be something
as intellectual as what we're talking
about now it could be something as
simple as helping someone else in their
own troubles lending a hand there are
many many ways but the solution in
general is
to get out of that current rats rut by
opening it up to bigger and without fail
yeah that works
yeah and to the degree that you that we
can learn how to do that I think that's
how we do it that I mean I I believe
that's gonna be the future of addressing
our mental illness is to be able to
design for and evoke experiences that
obliterate our mental models of the
world especially when those frameworks
of interpretation or those lenses of
perception are not serving us a
sufficiently powerful inverse PTSD
experience has the uncanny capacity to
take the lenses you see through and with
and make you actually see the lenses
because by lifting you by up leveling
you to that long view you not only see
the big picture but you see the limited
myopic way in which you were seeing your
own situation before and that
ontological shift seems to be what heals
us of our fractures I'm gonna end with
these words from this magnificent essay
by Ross Anderson he was writing about
the hubble space telescope and he was
talking about almost in poetic and
almost a religious term of what it that
did in terms of enlarging our humanity
couple lines and then and then we can
close out he said that to see the images
at the Deep Field photograph right
through that the Hubble made possible
was allowing us to essentially mainline
space and time through the optic nerve
feel the richness of that again
literally that's what's happening we're
mainlining space and time through the
optic nerves and that and that the
images were nothing less than an
ontological awakening and a forceful
reckoning with what is allowing us to
contemplate space and time on a scale
just shy of the infinite and then
finally through the sheer aesthetic
force of its discoveries again these
these images you feel contemplating
their vastness and Blake's world in a
grain of sand and heaven in a wild
flower and finiti of the palms of our
hands eternity in an hour through the
sheer aesthetic force of its discoveries
the Hubble distills
the complex abstractions of astrophysics
into singular expressions of color and
light vindicating Keith's famous
couplets
beauty is truth truth is beauty mm-hmm
yes it is I get that same throat when I
look at the deep field Hubble images and
it's something that I often refer people
to who have any kind of doubts about the
power of spirituality the power of
transcendent and the the role of
Technology in our lives because it was
technology that mainlined them that was
a technological achievement of a high
order to send a rocket into space with
this camera and so we are benefiting
from that shot of all because of
Technology and so I am a huge supporter
of our continual technological advance
of putting money into it of spending
time on it and paying the price of
consumer crap all right which is the
price that we have for these grand
achievements and I think that I also
have a you know kind of a an
encouragement to anybody who's working
in the company or field where they feel
as if well it's all kind of consumer
stuff we're making things that are being
thrown away or whatever yes that may be
true but at the same time you are part
of increasing the options of the world
the possibilities you are somehow making
available that next thing for that next
Shakespeare or Mozart or Einstein you
know van Gogh who's waiting that's right
for a tool that new tool that we are
actually part of this long long
of Technology through the universe
that's increasing the choices and
options and so we are part of that long
story so we can be proud of the fact
that we're working on these things and
even though they seem trivial they
actually in fact and one of the grandest
things that we could be doing on this
planet mm-hmm well Kevin I could talk to
you forever well thank you Jason for
having me it was fabulous what a plaque
forward to this for a long time is
really great to hear your poetry Thank
You likewise for those who are listening
he was not reading this he was reciting
it from memory it's it's it's a real to
real pleasure and I think what you're
doing is very very important which is
that there is another dimension to this
universe and there's another dimension
to this techno stuff it's it's deep it
has a spiritual dimension that it has a
divine dimension and I think you are
working hard to kind of make that
visible I don't have a choice I think
it's an important role thank you to do
because I think there is a tendency to
think of this stuff is cold yeah inhuman
disastrous disease all these negatives
but in fact I really believe that this
is one of the most human things that we
could be doing that it's overall a
tremendous good and in fact it is the
most human thing that we could be doing
thank you Kevin if you think quite a
pleasure already curia okay